earlier on this week no doubt you'll
have seen there was an IMF forecast for
for the global economy
um there was lots of focus on what
happened to the UK
um the UK seemed in their forecast to be
quite an outlier I just wanted to know
you know do you or the bank agree with
that assessment clearly this forecast is
about the UK but I just wonder does it
feel like we're an outlier does it feel
like we're doing so much worse than
everyone else and also you know what are
the reasons if so
um I'll commented um I mean we are our
forecast for UK growth are weaker this
calendar year
um than the Euro area or the US
um but I think one needs to be quite
careful about just taking a snippet of
time and we'll be looked to grow more
strongly than your area in 2022 and in
and over those three years as well 21 22
and 23 together
in our forecast and the IMs forecast
so you know there's a reasonable amount
of volatility over short periods of time
and you need to be careful in general
about those comparisons
having said that I think there are a
couple of things
that could have contributed to the
relative weakness of the UK that are not
just Pure Noise one the governor was
talking about a moment ago
which is the fact that participation
hasn't come back here in the same way it
has elsewhere we don't as Andrew said we
don't fully understand why but it's a
fact
another is that the UK is probably more
dependent on getting fat is more
dependent on gas
and there's a huge difference as you
know between the behavior of gas prices
in Europe and the United States so that
explains a big
part of the gap between growth here and
in your area compared with the us but
we're even more dependent than
Continental Europe
we think of France with all its nuclear
power stations for example
so I think that's another part of it
it may also be and this is what
um pay or the the IMs Chief Economist
said faster transmission of monetary
policy
all those things
the participation
the effect of high gas prices and even
the faster transmission and monetary
policy are not things that will endure
forever
so I don't think this had they you know
one should expect this to tell you about
Trends over the next four or five years
well brexit is as Andrew said in his
opening remarks has been something that
has pulled down potential output in our
country in our assessment that's been
our assessment for many years as you
know
and we have brought we've not changed
our estimate of the long run effects
but we've
brought some of them forward we think
probably they're coming in faster than
we first expected even in the long run
effect is no different
again I'm not sure that's going to help
you explain why growth is weaker having
than the Eurozone in 2023 haven't been
stronger in 2022
but it you know over periods of time yes
it's having some effect on growth
although ultimately in cumulatively no
bigger an effect than we we assess some
years ago
but you're right that based on the
numbers for trade and some degree on the
numbers for investment
we think those effects have come through
somewhat faster than we initially
envisaged it's interesting when you look
at the profile with the IMF because in
our profile as I would say I think we're
pretty similar this year we've both got
pretty sort of you know small negative
numbers actually the difference is what
happens thereafter I think which is that
they have growth picking up more rapidly
than we do that's the difference really
that stands out